hey youtubers is Charlie and since
marvel just confirmed josh brolin as
Thanos in guardians of the galaxy and
Avengers 2 I wanted to do a breakdown of
what that might look like it's actually
a bit of a surprise they announced
Avengers 2 because Ultron is the real
villain of that movie if you're finding
me for the first time I typically do
Marvel videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I know guardians is the next movie but I
kind of try to rotate the bonus videos
between Avengers and other stuff that's
going on so feel free to leave me
suggestions so let's talk about danos
first then guardians and then Avengers 2
in case you have no idea who that Oh
says he's currently the biggest villain
in the Marvel Universe you probably saw
him during the post-credits scene of the
first Avengers movie he's the one that
gave Loki his staff and was controlling
the re the reason why Marvel hasn't
mentioned him in any of the movies at
least by name yet is just because he's a
cosmic villain and we're just now
getting to guardians of the galaxy think
of it as like a Marvel progression of
evil you start out with Loki in male
cthe then you move up to the collector
in guardians and finally to the boss of
bosses
Thanos technically there are more
powerful figures in the comics like the
cosmic entity death she's actually part
of a lot of the fan of storylines
but I do not think that Marvel is gonna
use her in the movie universe so for now
Thanos is at the top of the food chain
he's the apex predator just like
Godzilla based on what Marvel has been
saying about him he'll probably have
minor roles in guardians of the galaxy
and Avengers to larger and guardians
lesser in Avengers 2 those films have
really big Castle ready so I'm not
expecting fan of Cecila named limelight
away from Benicio del Toro or James
Spader as Ultron but because Avengers 3
is supposed to culminate this infinity
gems Infinity Gauntlet storyline they
can't wait till 2018 or whenever they
release that movie
to just roll them out they have to kind
of tease them out as we go along the
story about the very first appearance of
Thanos is kind of funny because it ties
in with a lot of the changes they're
making to Ultron's origin in Avengers 2
so fans appeared for the first time in
1973 as part of this you know multi
comic book title storyline the first one
was Ironman Ironman number 55 to be
specific just to explain my Ultron
reference in case you didn't know Ultron
is going to evolve from stark tech owned
by the military and probably some sort
of tesseract energy
remember in the wake of shield
collapsing Tony Stark is going to be
privatizing world security that will
just lead to developing AI systems like
Jarvis for the military which is where
Ultron's coming from so it's starting to
make sense why they want to use Thanos
in Avengers 2 you know originally he
would have at least been a post-credits
scene but it sounds like now he's
actually gonna get like a real scene in
the actual movie or at least at the very
end but let's not get too off-track he's
in guardians of the galaxy you know in a
much bigger way so let's talk about what
that's probably going to look like so
we've seen pretty much the entire main
cast of guardians of the galaxy - the
big guy of course but we don't really
know what the actual MacGuffin is
whether it's one of the infinity gems or
some other object tied to the gauntlet
but the story they teased you know Ronan
in the accuser core attacking a planet
and the Guardians trying to save it
that's all surface level story the gems
in the gauntlet
that's what's hiding underneath so think
about it this way big army of accuser
core attacks the planet what's the
obvious reason for that attack and -
what's the secret reason who's pulling
Ronan the accuser strengths probably the
collector Benicio del Toro
he seems like a neutral figure even
though he's dressed like space Liberace
take it a step further though who's
pulling his strings
probably Thanos so rewind all the way
back to Thor the dark world the Warriors
3 at the end of the movie and that
post-credits scene gave the aether to
the collector that's basically one of
the infinity gems if you're a comic book
reader who's totally confused by them
substituting that weird red energy for a
physical gem remember the speech Odin
gave at the beginning of the dark world
he was telling the story of the infinity
gems he called them relics that predated
the creation of the universe he went on
to say that some of them exists in
different forms so like summit stones as
in gems and some exist like the aether
that also kind of implies that the
tesseract is one of the gems in a
different form my guess is that in
guardians of the galaxy that round
artifact star-lord is trying to steal is
one of the gems quick sidenote - it
hasn't been completely confirmed but I
think that what was powering Loki's
staff was the mind gem that's the one
that Baron von Strucker was
experimenting on at the end of Winter
Soldier
that's where Quicksilver and Scarlet
witch's powers were gonna come from yeah
I know they're changing a ton of
backstories
so what is Stannis going to be doing at
the end of guardians of the galaxy well
either he's going to be collecting the
gems from the collector or just
communicating with him about a mission
status update every time I've seen danos
in the comics he's always acted through
henchmen and servants he did punch the
out of hope during Marvel's
infinity event last year but generally
he does not dirty his hands unless one
of them is wearing a gem encrusted glove
that just happens to control all of
reality it was actually this comic book
story where he worked with the heroes so
he's actually kind of evolved into this
really complex character over time but I
think you know in guardians in Avengers
2 and Avengers 3 he's just gonna be a
flat-out villain just a big bad guy so
moving on to Avengers 2 you know using
Thanos in that story is a little bit
trickier because Ultron is the main
villain so how do you bring in someone
big and cosmic like dams without
overshadowing him they're changing a lot
of origin stories in the movie to kind
of align with this infinity gems plot
like Ultron's origins Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch and we know a couple
things
Loki's staff be a tesseract energy or
the mind gem however you want to think
about it is specifically where a lot of
those origins are gonna flow from in the
movie itself you know very different
from the comic books
remember Baron von Strucker talked about
us entering the age of miracles and he
was talking about the staff as it
applies to you know the creation of new
powers new life so you kind of see where
I'm going with this I think that Ultron
is gonna evolve from a combination of AI
stark tech like Jarvis interacting with
the same type of energy that gave
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch their
powers hail Hydra seriously though in
the wake of Winter Soldier Hydra is also
on the run just like shield is kind of
on the outs but Baron von strucker's
group is like a Hydra inside of Hydra
they're the ones that are really gonna
be behind all this stuff I think he is
gonna be directly responsible for the
creation of Ultron like he and Tony
Stark
are gonna accidentally give birth to a
deeply disturbed mechanical baby
so since the mind gem and the tesseract
are gonna be involved I think that
Thanos is just gonna show up to collect
those things I don't think he's gonna
care anything about what's going on
between Ultron and the Avengers they did
beat the outta me but they're
basically still flies on his radar at
this point but I'm really interested to
see if anything happens
during guardians of the galaxy or
Avengers 2 at least the early part of
the plot to change that you know because
it's implied that by Avengers 3 the
Avengers will meet Thanos directly in
combat it might end up being space
combat but combat is combat now it's
your turn though let me know in the
comments below what do you think about
Josh Brolin becoming the voice of Thanos
you know James Spader can do an amazing
Ultron I think Josh Brolin can pull it
off and I know I kind of in my head I
thought that you know he might make a
good Groot or at least Vin Diesel might
make a better Thanos but in reality I
think that they made the right choice so
because this came along super fast I'm
just moving my Maleficent review to
tomorrow morning and then obviously I'm
doing orphan black Saturday night then
fire and blood all of Sunday so be sure
to subscribe to get everything right now
you can actually click here to get my
breakdown of the last guardians of the
galaxy trailer and click here to learn
more about Avengers 2 thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you